all right so quick about me I'm a fifth
year PhD student in stats at NC State
I've been using Julia for the last two
years and so part of this is I basically
I'm doing all the implementation version
of my research into this package online
stats which is statistics for streaming
data and then I just kind of manage a
couple other toy projects in my spare
time so I have achieved histograms is
basically kernel density estimation with
a fine partition histogram and then I
have a sparse regression package which
is a basically like GLM net but it has a
few other models and uses a different
algorithm and then a few other kind of
toy projects that I like working on all
right um so I'm gonna talk about what is
julia so many of you probably went to
john Pearson's tutorial the other day so
some of this is gonna be review for
those of you who went there then why
would we use julia what is the current
state of julia for statistics and data
science how can I use julia alongside my
favorite stuff an R and Python and then
which are wishfully a packages provide
unique features so I kind of came up
with a short list of like what are the
cool things going on in Julia that I
have not seen elsewhere so kind of end
with that all right so from the website
Julia is a high level high performance
dynamic programming language for
technical computing with syntax that is
familiar to users of other technical
computing environments so does this
collection of great features that that
makes it work really fast and the
developers kind of say they can't just
take the the magic dust that makes Julia
fast you can't just spray people that on
some other language because they have
the set of features that work really
well together and that's how they get
performance so big part of this is the
JIT so this just-in-time compiler so
your code is compiled right before it's
run and this works in combination with
this great type system and type
inference and I'll talk quite a bit
about multiple dispatch another great
feature is macros and these are meta
programming tools so your write code
that writes more code so they're
essentially functions of expressions and
so macros alter your expression before
the code is actually run and there's a
whole lot of powerful things you can do
with that and then also arguments pass
by reference into functions so if you're
working with very large matrices you can
update things in place rather than
making copies
you get a lot of performance gains that
way all right so this is showing the JIT
in action here so the the mean function
in Julia is written in Julia and so
that's one kind of cool thing about
Julia is that so much of it is written
in its own language so the main function
the first time you call it it needs to
actually get compiled so I'm using this
app time macro and again so this is
basically getting the time stamp before
and after looking at the difference it
also tracks the number of allocations
that function does and then the total
number of allocations taken so the first
time you call it you might be you know a
little taken aback like why is this
simple mean function taking you know a
megabyte of memory but then when you see
when you call this function again it
just calls the Co compiled version and
you get no good performance there
that's legit so Julia is both dynamic
and compiled so here is a quick example
so I can write a generic function just f
of x equals x squared and I'm using this
code LLVM macro to take a look at the
code that's getting sent to the JIT and
the details of this aren't too important
but so I'm giving this function in in 64
and it's command julia is compiling a
method specific for in 64 types whereas
if I give my function a float 64 it
compiles a method specific for doubles
so this is really cool so you only
really need to worry about types if you
want to you still get this optimized
code even though I have not told Julia
anything about the type information so
this is the power of type inference and
the JIT at work here all right so the
the Julian way to do things is programs
are organized around multiple dispatch
and this is just a way of saying that
functions call different code depending
on the types of the arguments that you
give it so a great example here I think
is in the distributions package which is
one of the more mature julia libraries
but so with multiple dispatch your you
basically define like the right terms of
you want want to happen so here's an
example
so type or distributions are types in
the distributions package so I'm just
making a gamma 5 1 normal 0 1 and a beta
and then I'm evaluating the CDF
these three distributions at point five
so this is in I'm coming from the our
world so this is a big contrast to our
so in our you have like a P gamma and P
normal PB to functions so that's
something you should never do in Julia
so kind of rather than polluting the
namespace a little bit and Julia you
come up with ortho right like verb or
the right to name for your function and
then you define different methods
depending on the types that you give it
alright so I'm gonna go over an example
of just like the power of writing you
know generic code in Julia and it's
typically not a whole lot of extra work
especially if the abstract type
structure is has been well thought out
so I'm gonna go over just a very naive
quantile algorithm using Newton's method
so univariate distribution is an
abstract type to find in distributions
basically I know any concrete subtype of
univariate distributions as a method for
mean PDF and CDF and so what is glance
at this upper function here so here I'm
actually annotating the type so now I
want to enforce that the user is
providing a univariate distribution and
then I'm giving it a number so basically
I want to solve the CDF at theta equals
Q and that's that's how we define our
quantile so here is our Newton step here
and we can see like I'm passing D
through and deed needs to have a method
for me and a method for CDF and a method
for PDF and this thing is going to work
so I've defined this you know only one
time I haven't done anything specific
but this kind of immediately works for
gammas normals and betas or any other
univariate distribution I throw at it so
if I wanted to do this in R I would
basically so this I think is about ten
lines of code so if I were to do this an
R I would have to write you know ten
times as many distributions as I would
want to cover to do this algorithm so
this is the power of abstraction you
just save a whole lot of lines of code
and because of the JIT we still get
great performance out of these things so
it's just a really really cool tool all
right so why kind of like was I
originally interested in Julia
so even buzz besides kind of the cool
performance stuff it gets it's free it's
open source
most of julia is written in Julia so
this is awesome just because it's so
much easier to find out what's going on
so again coming from our if I want to
figure out what something's doing I'm
often you know ending up looking at C++
or Fortran code whereas and Julia I just
find myself writing or looking at julia
code into the same extent so this means
writing julia gives you expertise in
julia development which maybe sounds
pretty straightforward but if you're a
heavy hour user that doesn't really make
you proficient to write our packages
because try to go to our package you
need Fortran or C++
whereas in Julia you're getting
performance out of Julia so the more
familiar you are with it the more
capable you are of you know of writing
write a code for actual packages to
release to the public yeah and so this
is the idea that there's no two language
problem which comes up a lot when you
hear people talk about Julia the idea is
that prototype code goes into a high
level language like our and production
code goes to a low level language like
C++ so why we're using julia is because
there are major wins for language that
lends itself to both prototype and
production code alright so what is the
state of julia so here's a plot of the
number of tags packages over time so if
you look at july of 2015 we're sitting
at about 600 and a year later we're at
about a thousand so not quite doubling
but a pretty strong rates and then if we
look at the number of stars on github
over time
we can see a year ago we are at about
8,000 and we're now currently I don't
know 17,000 or so so I see this as a
good indicator that the the stars are
growing at a faster rate than the number
of packages just because I see the
number of packages I don't know as a as
a bad measure of the number of
contributors and stars as a bad measure
of the number of actual users so it's
good to see that users are increasing at
a faster rate than contributors in some
sense so are people taking Julia's
seriously so obviously I think yes and
so here is just couple of examples that
I kind of thought about so the New York
Fed has this model originally in MATLAB
DSGE dynamic stochastic general
equilibrium model which they moved over
into
Julia it's a really apparently a lot of
people use this I'm not completely
familiar with it but I know getting the
attention of like the Fed I think is
fairly significant my adviser works on a
project called Mendel which is
statistical analysis for genetics data
mostly snip data so they're transferring
this this gigantic codebase something
like sixty thousand lines of code of
fortran into julia and so i'm guessing
it's gonna be considerably less lines of
code once it's all in there but it's
it's a significant undertaking and just
the fact that they've they've chosen
this kind of like new open-source thing
so they originally just kind of
releasing executables and but now
they're just gonna have this completely
open source julia project julie has also
gotten the attention of intel labs so
they're working a couple other projects
that i thought about where this high
performance analytics toolkit HP jl
which is to my understanding is a
competitor to spark they give some
really impressive benchmarks and their
github page i don't know how coach who
those are
but they say they they beat sparking
logistic regression at least an example
they have and then a parallel like
accelerator packages
yeah which does a sepulchral
accelerations also this arbitrary
ranking system puts julia now in the top
50 so I think it's silly to rate
languages a little bit or like rank them
in a list because they do completely
different things but so julia is now 47
on this piyo v index so don't that
actually means anything but it's nice
that is at least getting a little bit of
attention
alright so specifically so what are the
tools for statistics and data science so
if you're heavier user of stats and data
science tools you want to take a good
look at this Julia stats organization so
stats space kind of covers a lot of the
functionality in our it provides like a
sample function if you want a sample
various values out of effector stats
base provides that it also provides a
lot of generic abstract methods for
things like model fitting and so it
defines part of the like the correct
language in order to analyze statistical
models with but it doesn't actually
implement any of these like fitting
so in staff space it defines like a fit
method and like a few other methods like
specific for linear models and then
there's packages like GLM here for
generalized linear models which
basically implements this abstract
definition and stat space so I mentioned
distributions for before and yeah I
definitely think that is one of the more
mature libraries in julia it's very very
cool use it all the time for stuff but
again it's just you pick kind of the
right interface on how to handle
distributions and then you come up with
this yeah it was correct interface and
then you like automatically know you
know how to get the PDF or the log PDF
of some distribution so data frames is
also similar to pandas it's recently
undergone some pretty big changes so I
think just recently there's a PR that
just got pulled in
so now nullable arrays is now kind of
the backend for data frames and nullable
arrays so that was a google Summer of
Code project from last year so julia
does not have missing data in the
language by default like r does so
nullable arrays is one way to to get
this functionality and so there were
some performance complications with data
frames in the past some issues with type
stability and some other things working
with missing values gets tricky
because you might have a missing value
or a float 64 or you might have missing
and you know some other object so it's
hard to give the compiler information on
you know what you're actually giving it
so null arrays is this nice performant
package and it's now yeah kind of the
the backend for data frames and there's
also quite a bit of stuff going on with
other data tables structures but I'll
talk a little bit more on that another
cool package is mixed models so this is
Doug Bates so he is one of our core
members so I think there's 20 or so our
core members that have commit access to
our and so he is no longer working on
our because he switched to Juliet but if
you're familiar with our key does the
LME for linear mixed effects models and
the matrix package which gives you a
sparse matrix support and our sparse
matrix support is native in Julia so we
don't need anything like that
so I really like this quote that I came
across a while ago so as some of you may
know I have had a rather late midlife
crisis and run off with another language
called Julia so that sucked weights in
the network group so kind of getting him
to switch I considered kind of a big win
for Julia
so he's contributed a lot to this Julia
staff stuff and yeah he has this great
mixed models package and that Julia Khan
last year he was presenting and he had a
ten minute lightening talk and during
his talk he fit his model in Julia and
he said it took a better part of a day
when he fit it in are so he's obviously
impressed with the kind of the
performance implications of switching to
this fast cool new language so I think
that's pretty exciting just to get the
attention of I don't know some older
folks as well as the well the younger
and all people like to try new stuff so
for a general optimization so there's an
optimization package in peer Julia
called Optimo does a lot of cool stuff
and then there's also optimization
packages that use back-end solvers so if
you're familiar with like most I can
grow B so those are pay things unless
you have a dot edu email address like I
do but so there's jump and come back CJ
l so convexity L is Stephen Boyd's from
Stanford's kind of discipline convex
programming implementation but it's very
very cool all right so some of the
up-and-coming things that I'm pretty
excited about for Julia
so I'm working with this organization
called Julia ml you can look up myself
on github and kind of see what we're
working on and so currently the only
thing that's in metadata which is the
thing that allows you to just do package
dot add whatever package and julia is
this losses package so her goal is to
come up with a whole bunch of
abstractions for machine learning
so in this losses package we have things
like you know l2 loss and l1 loss and
thanks for quantile regression and
support vector machines and there's a
whole bunch of abstractions and then how
do you get the derivatives of these
things so these are kind of the we want
to at least start by kind of
implementing all like the primitives
that we'd use for for machine learning
so we have a losses package we're also
working on this transformations package
so a transformation could be anything
from I don't like an SVD or a PCA or
this could be just a linear predictor so
you can combine transformations with
losses and then we're also working on a
penalties package so you can add things
like elastic net and scat or lasso or
your favorite ones of those Anthony you
kind of play around with these these
primitive pieces that should be easy to
work with but I'm pretty excited about
this stuff in January so on the the
julia blog think of simon burn posted
something about the the statistics
roadmap for julia so they got a
considerable chunk of funding and a big
part of that was improving the
statistics states and julia a big part
of that is data frames and I think that
motivated part of the work for an
all-over nullable arrays and some of
those things but so there's some very
cool things yeah coming up which I feel
like so people were saying that several
years ago and we keep saying that over
and over I think the closer we get to
version one like the more cool cool
things start to look you know more
stable so we're getting there even if
we're not quite there yet so some of the
data table developments so there's a
Google some of Summer of Code project
which is called J play are very subtle
reference to the apply R and R and
that's the same student David gold who
worked on novel arrays last year
actually I have a very quick so he's
actually implement as his own data table
type and then he's basically coming up
with macros which which correlate well
with the same verbs that are being used
in deeply R so I think that's a very
cool tool a very similar in scope is a
project called query JL and they say you
can filter project join and group data
from any iterable data source so I've
not tried query so J player I think
works really well and then there's also
was a talk at Julia Khan about this
abstract tables JL which there hasn't
been a whole lot of traction on but I'm
really interested in this idea so the
idea is you come up with write the the
correct interface on how do you access
table like data so you need to define
for an abstract table type how do I get
a column how do I get a row how do I get
subsets
and then you can write algorithms for
generic abstract table types because you
have the interface for accessing all
these things already set so David gold
the J player guy has an example or a
quick demo of abstract tables that he's
implemented so yeah it needs a little
bit of traction but I think it's a very
cool idea and I kind of hope it goes
through all right so how can I use julia
alongside our and Python so obviously
there's a whole lot of things in our and
Python that like are already good and we
don't want to necessarily implement
everything in Julia so one of the main
ones is PI call so this is allows you to
call python from Julia this is heavily
used some packages are basically just
wrappers using PI call so PI plot JL is
essentially just yeah calling straight
Python and there's also a scikit-learn
JL one cool thing about this so if if
there's a model in Python you can call
that and then it also supports a whole
bunch of julia machine learning models
so you kind of call either one from
Python or from Julia so here is a quick
example using PI import or sorry using
pi call and PI call as this pike import
macro so I can import the math module
and then I can now just use that like
normal Python and it's a great thing
that the syntax in julia is close enough
to python so it looks pretty much the
same and here's a quick example of using
pi plot just plot Rand in and even
though I'm in a Julia kernel yeah that
shows up in my Jupiter notebook things
work nicely
all right so I'm coming from the art
world I guess keep saying but so our
call is you to call are from Julia and
you can also use Julia objects within
art so here is a very quick example so
using our call I'm making a random
vector of five random normal zero ones
and then I have this our string macro
which basically is telling this to throw
this thing into our and then I'm also
interpolating this value X which is from
Julia so I have a Julia value I'm
throwing this into are getting the
absolute values and then I'm returning
this art object back to Julia so this
this interpolation stuff is is really
very cool I'm pretty excited about that
and so in Julia there are various rebel
modes so if you do a question mark you
get help
oh yeah I'm sorry there we go so yeah
question mark gives you a help mode does
a fuzzy search and it also returns the
doc string if you if you get it
correctly and then if I hit semicolon I
get the shell and then are call ads in
our mode so I can now load ggplot2 you
or oops too used to Julia and I can just
kind of operate in our like normal and
then I can just switch back to Julia
real quick and you kind of have this
great Interop stuff so one thing I was
used to a lot more so I was I was very
comfortable with plotting and our unless
comfortable with plotting and Julia so
this is easy enough to do enjoy and
Julia is just a call
you know the are based plotting package
or if I want to be a little bit fancier
I can load you to plot to you and all
this stuff just kind of works so I'm I'm
interpolating these values that I'm
providing from Julia but I'm plotting
them within Gigi plots you alright so
now I'm gonna talk about the the Julia
package that I think are contributing
these really cool unique things for data
science and so I keep saying this over
and over but I really like distributions
so basically yeah it just
this great interface and you know how to
work with everything so I won't harp on
this too much but it's it's really great
for writing abstract code like you can
write a Gibbs sampler that is very
abstract and kind of switch out your
priors really easily and yeah do a whole
bunch of cool stuff so the state of
plotting in Julia was a bit messy for a
while so there's no base plotting
structure quite in Julia so there's a
whole bunch of different planning
packages
they all have different syntaxes for how
to use them so it's just a little bit
messy so most people use gadfly and I
think that's still probably the most
popular one but the guide fly developer
actually kind of went mi a six eight
months ago or so and has not been
contributing so the future of gadfly I
think is a little bit uncertain at the
moment so I'm a very big fan of this
package called plots Jael and this is by
Tom Bri laughs he's another guy in the
Julia ml organization but he does a lot
of really cool stuff so basically what
he is defined here is a smart unifying
syntax for a whole bunch of different
plotting libraries so you don't really
worry about which Beck and plotting
library is actually rendering this
visualization you just kind of worry
about getting the syntax right for plots
and then you can switch between
different backends so he you're
basically just assembling a dictionary
of arguments and then for whatever
backend it figures out how to pass that
dictionary as arguments into the backend
so you don't have to learn the separate
syntaxes for pipe lot or gr or plotly j
s which is interactive JavaScript or
unicode plots which plots right and your
repple or PG f plots which is for
plotting in latex and there's more in
the works so here's an example of that
so I initialize a back end by the
package name as a function I'll a lower
case so I'm initializing PI plot and
then I'm plotting this value I'm giving
it a 100 by 2 matrix and plots knows
that I probably want to plot two series
of length 100 rather than 100 series in
length 2 and then I can immediately
switch to the gr back-end and I plot
this looks a little bit different and
then I can also switch to plot Li the
cool thing about plot leus I know have
all this cool interactivity and I can I
don't know play around with all my stuff
and I don't have to learn JavaScript or
I don't have to learn their specific
Python API
or julia api i can just kind of play
around of things that's normal and i can
just switch back and forth between
backends so i might want some cool
interactive stuff while i'm playing
around with data and then when i switch
to publication i can just kind of switch
the backend of Pi plot and have a
publication ready visualization so plus
also supports a number of cool things
that the the backend itself might not
support so plots defines its own
animation things so it defines a Jif
macro so basically what this does is for
every plot that I produce in this for
loop it's going to save a frame for
every 10 of those so I'm making a for
loop of 101 thousand I'm just adding a
random normals here one to my plots and
then I'm plotting the frames and I
automatically get this cool jiff then I
can present to you and it looks nice
alright so this is a bit same shameless
self-promotion but this is the project
that I'm working on mainly called online
stats so this is streaming algorithms
for statistics and kind of one of the
main features is it gives you options on
how new observations should influence
your model so here is a very quick
example of this so I'm giving a mean of
an equal weight so all these types that
I define an online stats are
parameterised by how new observations
should weight the model so an equal
weight is going to do things
analytically an exponential weight is
going to give it a constant weight of
point zero one for every single
observation so say I just have some data
stream and I'm fitting these things so
here's one quick example of what this
might look like so say my model is
actually changing over time so I have
the streaming data coming in this red
line is the equally weighted mean and
this blue line is exponentially weighted
so we can see that this red line ends up
estimating completely the wrong thing
and that's just because of this thing
called parameter drift like our are true
parameters are changing over time so if
we're just calculating a mean we're
estimating the wrong thing but we can
just plug in a different weight into
this thing and we end up estimating the
correct thing with exponentially so a
mean is a very simple example but the
same parameter drift can occur in GLM's
or support vector machines or anything
else
so there's also ways to yeah keep this
idea of of waiting observations new
observations differently but a type that
I'm very proud of is what I'm calling
stat learn it's just a statistical
learning with regularization and all
these things are used to cast
approximation but basically because
they're using these approximations they
can kind of catch up with parameter
drift as things are changing over time
but this can do elastic net type
penalties with yeah GLM's quantile
regression support vector machines
Hebrew lost and absolute loss regression
and this is kind of another example of
using abstract code and Julia like I
don't have different algorithms
implemented for every single one of
these I've implemented these things once
and this all of these like lost types
have you know the same unifying
interface that you can just pass these
loss functions to
so again so I mean abstractions are
constantly the theme I'm talking about
with Julia but here's another cool thing
that I think is going on called data
streams so this abstraction for
transferring table-like data from one
source to another so if you have a data
frame and you want to pass that to a
feather data frame which is a cool
back-end or language agnostic way of
passing data between like R and Python
and Julia there's a number of other
stuff but Hadley Wickham and West
McKinney of pandas Fame have been
working on this and then yes if you have
a CSV file and want to pass that into a
data frame so basically he's come up
with the the correct language of how do
you pass data tables from one source to
another it's a very small package and
you just kind of need to define a few
extra methods and then all these
abstract methods kind of take over and
know how to handle your data from
transferring one to another all right so
we're very close to Duke so some of you
are probably basting is by osmosis
so mama is a very cool package for MCMC
and Julia so it's pure Julia which i
think is pretty unique so when you're
using things in are you're probably
calling wind bugs or Jags or Stan and
those are great things but if you want
to figure out what's going on you don't
get to look at it in the language of
your choice you get to look at it and
you know they're languages so mom was
very cool again has this very cool
abstract structure and you can going to
just throw around different pieces of
priors and likelihoods and things just
work and they're fast and it's all on
Julia so if something's wrong you can
take a look at it really quick all right
so those are the cool things that I've
yeah kind of discovered and I'm very
excited for Julia all right so julie has
a great start so it's been about four
years since the first public appearance
of its there's fewer breaking changes
with every release so I've gone through
the panes of 0.3 to 0.4 and I am now on
0.5 it was definitely easier point four
to 0.5 I think then in 3 to 4 and the
developers have stated basically they
they want a release by the end of next
summer and they're planning on one more
point released before that and part of
that is just to make room for
deprecation more
so there's going to be a point six and
then hopefully the next version is one
point now so Julia is right for
implementing your own algorithms so I'm
very hesitant to try overselling Julia
because I think it's great because it's
perfect for me because I'm implementing
all my own research I'm hard coding my
algorithms I don't have a whole lot of
dependencies but if you have a complex
long-term long-term project it's gonna
need a lot more maintenance compared to
Python especially if you have a lot of
dependencies just because everything is
still a little bit of a moving target
even though a lot has settled down but
that is all I have thinking